average it Roy was a Bangladeshi
American activist he was well known in
Bangladesh for his blog written in
Bengali in February a widget and his
wife rafita were attacked in Dhaka she
survived my husband wasn't as lucky he
was a true target of that hackers to
successfully hacked him to death police
say the attackers were religious
fundamentalists rafidah has now taken
over the blog her courage has been
awarded with a best of online activism
award the jury picked Bonnie's blog in
the social change category and called
for the protection of activists now it
is the role of the wider community to
protect them to shelter them and ensure
that the lies that have gone do not go
in vain the prizes have been awarded to
online activists from around the world
for the last 11 years this year an award
was also given to a video game zaitoon
the little refugee aims to draw
attention to the reality of Palestinian
and Syrian refugees and to the Mexican
blog Rancho electronical which aims to
help people understand technology and
protect their privacy all the winners
have one thing in common they are
changing the societies around them